[Music]
but let's go and everybody ready let's
go let's get a 10 minute game in
and let's see
who the field will give us today 1805
okay
so
we've been playing d4 for the last
couple of games i want to explore
positional themes a little bit more uh
today
um i'm in a positional mood for some
reason now we're going to play the main
lines we're not going to play the london
we're going to play d4 and c4
and we have another king's indian slash
grunfeld
so
you know as per usual we're going to
play knight c3
and he plays the kings india now
yesterday we faced uh the grunfeld we
faced d5 in this position
bishop g7 is the entrance to the king's
indian because black allows white to
play e4
and d6 main line now there's a thousand
variations that we could play in the
king's indian the one that i have
historically chosen
um in the speed run is the samish
which is the move f3 which is widely
considered to be the most tactical line
of the king's indian
and for you know against players in the
18 1900 range it presents a great deal
of challenges because it's usually not
as well studied by players
but we don't have to play the same ish
today um and i can introduce you guys to
let's just say another line
and what i want to play today is
something called the outer back
variation
and i want to explore i want to branch
out the outer back variation starts by
playing bishop to e2 so this is a bit of
an awkward looking move you're
developing the bishop first
and the move knight f3 transposes to the
classical variation which is also
considered the main line
but we're going to play bishop g5
and this is the averback and in the
abber back you develop both of the
bishops before this night
which has and i'm not a big aberbach
expert it's not like i know exactly what
to do with white
um but it's a very flexible opening
because by refraining from developing
this knight you are opening uh
up the possibility
of a quick king side attack you can
actually go h4 in this position
and with the contact of the h5 square
unobstructed by the knight you're going
to be threatening a quick h5
and that's exactly what we're going to
do we're going to play this
traditionally and play h4 in this
position
he plays h6 now why you might ask are we
putting the bishop on g5 if it's very
easy to chase away so what's the
explanation for that why didn't we
straight away put the bishop on e3 why
allow h6
yeah we want to induce a weakness
and not only do we want to induce a
weakness this is a hook after we play h5
and he plays g5 the f5 square might be
very weak
so there's a lot of reasons for
inducing a move like h6
all right
um
so you go z5
now those of you who've played the kings
indian
a good amount
um
you know you should know
one second
okay so let's see
should we close the center should we
take we should absolutely close the
center since we're attacking on the
king's side we should close up the
center so that we can focus our efforts
on the king's side he goes b6 that's a
weird move i don't think that really
does anything that's not a king's indian
type of move and that gives us basically
free reign to attack on the king's side
there's many ways that
we can go about
attacking on the king's side
there's a more positional approach to
the king side in a more tactical
approach
the tactical approach is to go for his
throat let's go g4 g5 try to open up the
h-file checkmate him traditionally
i'll show you guys the more positional
approach after the game
but we could also start by inducing a
slightly awkward move so we could play
queen to d2 here preparing to castle
along in case we need to but we don't
need to rush with that and obviously
also attacking the h7 h6 spun trying
trying to get him to go king h7 which
could be a very vulnerable king later if
the h file opens
thank you chur baban and eats gummy
worms and now we're going to go for his
throat g4
let's begin attacking and because the
sensor is closed you guys might be
looking at this with a little bit of
confusion how how am i getting away with
uh pushing that pushing these king side
pawns
and now we need to defend this spawn so
we're going to play f3 how am i getting
away with all of this well again the
center is closed the rules are different
when the center is closed it's just not
necessary to develop all of your pieces
at once
now we need to be careful about in terms
of how we
attack
because if we play g5 too early if we
play g5 here which i'm sure a lot of you
are tempted to play
he's going to blockade the whole attack
by putting his knight on h5
we can take on h6 he drops his bishop
back using that pawn as cover
that doesn't really accomplish anything
so
we need to play in a little bit of a
more crafty way and in order to do that
we will need to complete our development
so can we complete our development is it
even possible
is there anywhere to put this knight
well there is you can play knight h3
what is the knight doing there well the
knight's doing a lot of things on h3 it
is supporting the move g5
later on it can leap to g5
that scenario can occur if this pawn
disappears from h6 maybe it will take on
h6 and then play knight g5 check or you
could sacrifice it on g5 in some
variations so the knight on h3 is doing
a great deal of things and if it
ends up
uh interfering in our attack we can
always in a very samish-like idea we can
play knight f2 uh and that knight is
going to be a very good one it's going
to support e4 it's going to support g4
that's a perfectly serviceable knight
okay
now once again the question i think he's
trying to go king g8 evacuating his king
from the immediate danger zone
um
and that basically gives us one tempo to
decide if we want to play g5 or not if
we're gonna play g5 we should play it
now
if we don't play g5 then we can sort of
unhurriedly castle and
prepare the second wave of attack
i don't see the need to go g5 i don't
see the need to rush
on the other hand if we don't rush and
he evacuates his king we might have a
hard time um getting the attack started
again
even if he runs his king to e8 he's not
going to be out of the woods because
we're going to be able to play f4 we're
always going to be able to open up the
center so
a case could be made either way
but let's do it i want to see what
happens let's go g5
this is a very double-edged move i don't
know if this is good or not but we'll
see how he reacts to this
i think a very professional move would
be to take on g5 paradoxically enough
now that he's prepared king g8 i think
taking would be a good idea
and we might want to take with a bishop
in order to pin his knight to his queen
so that he doesn't jump around to h5 and
other squares
oh it's all good
but but thanks knight g a very passive
move
very passive move
and immediately that sends a signal to
my head that his king on h7 is boxed in
the time has come for us
to
make things go boom
the time has come for us to make things
go boom
so what does that even mean should we
take on h6 is that a good idea
well that's not a great idea then he can
take with the knight and he'll have the
g8 square again this is a golden
opportunity for us to make things go
boom go h5 i'm not even calculating this
move the worst thing that can happen is
we lose a pawn big whoop we lost the
pawn look at how many files we are
forcing open to the smoke
i smell a lot of stuff i smell the
g-file being open
how can we occupy the g-file in the
fastest possible way
obviously rook g1 assuming uh it's bad
because it blunders the knight
what do we have in reserve and this
probably is going to be our next two
moves yeah we're going to castle then
we're going to put this other rook on g1
and then we're going to have everything
positioned perfectly on the on the king
side
um
now you don't need to panic when you
reach i see some players they they reach
these positions they do everything right
and then they somehow panic oh you know
so much is going i don't know what's
going on
you don't need to treat this as if this
is some sort of
you know you're you're uh some sort of a
molecular biologist performing an
experiment i mean this is
relatively simple position there's a lot
of tension going on but let him be the
one to take your pawns you don't need to
do anything
you just need to recapture the pieces
that are being captured and bring more
pieces into into the attack
and when he decides to open up files or
engage us then we're going to react
accordingly you don't need to go crazy
preliminarily because you know there's a
lot going on
okay so if he takes on g5 we'll take
back if he takes on h5
we'll either take back or we'll lose
castle
the other thing to remember in such
positions on that topic is that you
don't always need to recapture if he
captures a pawn maybe we'll decide to
castle maybe we don't need to recapture
the pawn maybe we don't want to waste a
move maybe it's more important to bring
more pieces in the attack
so that's another thing you have to turn
the autopilot off when you're attacking
like this when you're close to checkmate
sometimes it's much more important to
bring another rook into the attack than
to
restore material equality thank you zeus
909 and openob
but
yeah so this is a great example of that
goshi takes h5
taking on h5
is not a bad move that opens up the h
file that actually seems
quite appealing
but
i would also argue at the same time
where is the spawn going is he really
going to defend the spawn on h5 is that
pawn going to run away from us
i mean those are all rhetorical
questions because the answer is clearly
no
i think f4 is premature i think f4 helps
his bishop get open i think we have a
pretty clear developing move that we
still need to play
what am i talking about what is the move
that we haven't played yet it's clear to
me that it's this particular piece is
missing in the act missing in action the
rook on a1 we need to involve the rook
once we have two rooks in the attack i
feel like he won't have enough forces to
defend
yeah we need to castle long
and uh the situation on the ground for
him is
uh critical because of how passive he is
he doesn't have any any active counter
play
uh which is which makes the king's
indian very hard to play um if you don't
get active counter play you're just
going to get smothered
which is what's happening here
then we can take on h5 and play rook h1
with g1 depending on how he positions
his pieces we're going to choose our
uh piece placement accordingly
thank you mr ayu for the prime
appreciate it of course
well i mean
castles is a patient move but it's also
a developing move it's it's pretty
natural i think you want your king to be
safe when you're attacking you don't
want to keep thinking about oh what
happens if the attack backfires
yeah rogue g1 or rook h1 depending on
what he does because either the g-file
might be the more important one he goes
king g6 so that gives us a clue about
how to react and it should be pretty
obvious to you guys which what we should
do now
whoa jim jam with the 25 damn girl it's
rook gwan of course tam
we got a lot of action in the house
tonight
25 my gosh
all right
yeah we're down upon i think we'll
resign now
i think we'll resign now
no king g6 was a panic move maybe he
could have resisted a little bit better
but um
i honestly don't think he had enough
firepower there
i don't think he has enough firepower
there
this is gg
donna
wait i don't get the reference
f6 will play g takes h6 check and take
the bishop okay he goes back which to
his credit is the best move
to his credit this is the best moment
how what should be the order of
operations
um
how should we
what should we do
it doesn't matter actually oh his clock
is frozen
sorry
yeah i don't know why this happens um
sorry let me just
all right this should be good oh no his
clock is not frozen it's 401
yeah so i would play rook h5 i mean
you can play g takes h6 but i'll show
you guys after the game why it might be
a good idea to keep the tension
um
in general again notice how i'm not
taking anything i don't need to take i'm
i'm reserving all of my options because
maybe i'll want to go g7 maybe he'll go
f6 and i'll go g6 checkmate this is not
going anywhere he's not going to defend
the g pawn
uh the h-bond that is
furthermore he might want to try to hide
under the um
shadow of the h-bond so maybe we don't
want to take it all
maybe we want to hold this over when in
fact i think we do
now let me think about this for a second
i actually want to calculate
this guy is incredibly resilient i have
to give him a lot of credit he's
tremendously resilient
um
it's not that easy to finish off these
attacks
not at all
yeah time for us to open some more stuff
up with f4 let's go f4 opening
everything else up trying to get his
bishop out of the picture uh just
blasting the center
and i'll talk about other moves after
the game and this is a complex attack
i'm not going to pretend this is simple
um at the same time i have two minutes
left i don't want to
sit around and lose on time but now i
think i found the winning idea
and the way that i found the winning
idea is that i noticed that the queen on
d2 that's the missing piece it's time to
involve the queen
but the queen is boxed in by our own
bishops can we get the queen involved
efficiently with tempo forcing him to
react to something while we involve our
queen
and this move otherwise would be very
bad from a positional standpoint it's a
terrible move we don't want to do this
we take the knight
we don't want to take the knight from a
position why are we opening up the b
file for him the stark squared bishop is
important but it's far more important
for us to get our queen involved in the
attack onto f4 so that i can
attack f7 and threaten all these
checkmates that's far more important
than anything else in my opinion
obviously maybe i'm wrong
um
attacking is one of the hardest
okay but now he's blunted f7
and that was what i calculated and what
are we threatening in this position and
this is the unstoppable threat this ends
the attack
i'm okay well i didn't see how i could
have finished it earlier aquila but i
i'm sure i didn't play accurately that's
for sure rook takes h6 as mate
i'm sure i didn't play entirely
accurately 100
um it seems like i could have finished
this earlier but
this just shows you how complicated
attacking is
yeah rook takes h6 is checkmate because
he can't take with the king it's
defended he can't take with the bishop
because the bishop is pinned by the by
the queen
banakil exactly
nice
i'm pumped at that game there's a lot to
talk about
so if you were a little bit overwhelmed
while the attack was going on
now is the time to
listen carefully because i'll try to
explain the logic behind every attacking
move
so we decided this game to play the
average back which is bishop b2 and
bishop g5
and the landscape of the king's indian
is very vast
the landscape of the king's indian is
very vast white has a million different
lines
the main line or the classical variation
is just to develop normally knight f3
and bishop b2 and as you guys have seen
from my games from my black games
castles and then either knight c6 or ed4
so in this position you've seen me go
knight bd7 knight c6 knight a6
million different moves
um but in this game we decided on the
outer back variation bishop to bishop
chief now what is the idea of developing
this bishop to g5 as i already explained
there are several ideas first of all
this move can be thought of
prophylactically um
i am actually preventing him from going
e5
can anybody tell me why and i would be
pretty impressed if somebody could
figure this out um
if somebody could figure this out
without having seen this line before
white to play white is already winning
or not winning but white is much better
it's
this is a bad move for black and this is
a trap that you could set freaking is it
for inexperienced kings indian players
and they might fall into it
okay
yeah knight c5 at the end is correct
take everything bishop f6 and knight d5
so takes takes
takes takes thank you chuck i appreciate
it
and
i think the most accurate move order is
to take first then play knight d5 you're
forking f6 and c7 this looks like it
wins on the spot but black can play
knight d7 black can uh limit the losses
to a pawn but in addition to everything
else black is going to be kind of
paralyzed the knight's going to have
this outpost
so this is
uh this is a disaster a small time
disaster for black
so
[Music]
um
so black has to make alternative
arrangements
knight t5 without bishop f6 is better
yeah see embarrassingly i don't even
know yeah apparently this is better
apparently this is the best move because
if you if you take on d5 you drop the
exchange
um and so black has to make different
arrangements and there are many ways to
do that black can move the queen out to
e8 this is a very weird looking move
this is actually the most popular move
the idea is to prepare e5 you are
getting out of the pin
uh and this move should make sense to
everybody now you just need to prepare
e5 you can also say all right well
you're not gonna let me play e5 i'm
gonna play c5 and i'm gonna play this
like a bononi this is also one of the
more reputable lines because the bishop
on g5 could be misplaced in the binoni
you could also play knight bd7 this is
the old school move this is what my
opponent played
and the upper back was first played in
1930 averbach himself only played it uh
in the 50s he was the most famous one to
play in the first you know 20 30 years
was played thank you for the five months
zoidberg appreciate it
so we decide on h4 which is a very
tactical way to play the average back
um
queen d2 is the main move
queen d2 is the main move
um i'm checking whatever back himself
never faced knight bd7 queen d2 has 2
000 games
h4 only 81 games but it's been played by
some gm's
um so you can see that i've never played
the outer back with white so i was
experimenting too
and apparently the main line is queen d2
but it has a similar idea i mean you're
trying to go bishop h6 so this is a
pretty tactical line
when you're trying to trade the king's
indian bishop and eventually you might
go h4h5 e5 d5 knight c5 f3 so in many
ways this resembles the same-ish i i
tried to avoid playing the same-ish and
look where we ended up we ended up in a
very similar position so sorry about
that
um so we played h4
and black played h6
which let me see out of the 81 games
that featured the move h4
which i'm sure the computer laughs at c5
is the main move
and uh in the game
albert against benjamin that was the
highest rated game to reach this
position u.s championship 1983.
so not a bunch of jokers lev albert
against
um against joel benjamin two very strong
gm's
um
c5 d5 b5 and albert decided to play it
like a benko gambit
and the reason for that is that white
hasn't completed the kingside
development and the king isn't really
going to go to the king side because
well now you have this h pawn sticking
out so playing at banco gambit style
makes a lot of sense and you'll you'll
often see black doing this in the outer
back
um any i don't want to bog ourselves
down too much i think h6 is fine
bishop b3 i think he played fine e5 d5
maybe white is a tiny bit better here
but this is where our opponent started
going astray this move b6
uh is a is a very serious mistake and
when you play an opening like the king's
indian
you know
you get a reward but you have to pay the
entrance fee the reward is that you're
almost always going to get winning
chances you guaran there's almost no
lines in the king's indian where white
is able to force a draw not so queen's
gambit slav why can play exchange slav
um you know nimzo indian there's very
peaceful positional lines in king's
indian you almost always guarantee
pretty tactical complex struggle on the
flip side if black plays a single
inaccurate move even an innocuous
looking one
white's going to get that extra tempo
and that potentially is going to be
disastrous
exchange king's indian yes but you can
decide you can sidestep the exchange
king's indian uh if you don't want to
face the exchange you can play knight
bd7 first and this transposes to the uh
to the old main line which is not
considered to be amazing for black but
you can play this
um i've played it myself and even in the
exchange there are some lines where it's
not a dead draw
black can definitely
make attempts for the of course white
can make a draw if he's accurate but
that's basically true anywhere
um but anyways b6 is a waste of time
i'm pretty sure that my opponent was
afraid of going knight c5 because he
didn't want to allow bishop c5 dc he
thought that this was a bad pawn
structure and i who can blame him for
that but it turns out that in the king's
indian
this type of trade unless there are
mitigating factors is a disaster for
white it's a disaster for white because
look at the dark squares all these dark
squares are now incredibly weak
there's nothing to attack h6 with you
can play queen d2 you're not threatening
anything
and this d6 square
those of you familiar with basic
positional ideas how should black
continue here this is a classic idea
how should black continue in this
position the moment you see a square
like this in a pawn like this
you know you should kind of snap your
fingers
and think of the idea of going 98 96
um
transferring the knight to this very
important blockading square and that
knight is going to be an amazing
multitasker you might prepare f5 if
white castles kingside or a6 and b5 if
white castle's queen side
i can show you right off the top of my
head i can show you games where i
either had this kind of idea or i missed
it and i never forgot the lesson that i
should have learned that you know i
never forgot that i should have played
it
perhaps my most painful experience
in this line
uh was in the world youth chess
championship in 2007
which
uh which i won
and i only lost one game that tournament
and um
that game taught me this crucial lesson
about transferring the knight to d6 in
these types of positions
so
if you're attentive to the lessons you
learned from your losses then you become
better this was the position
um where my coach literally yelled at me
because i was 2100 i should have known
this idea here here you see the d5 pawn
this is a very king's indian like
position
very kings indian like there is no pawn
on c4 this was a perk but the ideas are
exactly the same i should have gone here
and then here and then here and black is
better but instead i thought well this
bond is annoying let me trade it off by
playing c6
and obviously well this leads to a
terrible pawn structure this gives white
a very big initiative you can just see
him
leaping onto my bishop on g7 is terrible
and i ended up losing so
i never forgot that uh forgot that
lesson i correctly understood that the
pawn is annoying but instead of
blockading it i tried to trade it that
benefited white entirely
all right
so
sorry to spend so long on this um
on these moments i think just this is
pretty important for understanding the
position
okay
so b6 is a waste of time this gives us
an opportunity to develop the queen
and
begin the kingside attack
begin to begin the king side attack
um and after knight c5 we defend with f3
notice that we do not we do not take on
c5 here under almost any circumstances
note the word almost
so f3
a5
and now knight h3
so again why didn't we play g5
immediately because after knight h5
it's going to be very hard to make
progress because of this blockading
knight g takes h6 bishop f6 and
he's starting to attack this spawn
the knight can go on to f4 later you
guys should all kind of see that it's
very very difficult for white to get
anything done now on the king's side so
you can only go g5 once
um and when you go g5 you got to make
sure to make it count
so we decided to go knight h3 preparing
g5
and rook h8 by our opponent which i
think is an okay move i think it's
interesting after g5
well well his knight is hanging the
problem is that his knight is hanging so
he has to respond to that that's why yes
if if the knight wasn't on f6 he would
have played h5
um
and knight g8 was i think the decisive
mistake it's too passive
and not only is it too passive but he
allows us to play h5 ripping everything
open which
again is is
utterly disastrous
what should he have done he should have
gone knight h5 or g takes h
which takes g5 because here
i was planning to take on h6 and in
contrast to the previous version what
additional move does white now have
and that's why we put the knight on h3 i
explained this during the game
knight g5 check
yeah and he i mean i guess he can play
here but then age seven is annoying
and if bishop g5 hg
and we get this incredibly strong
protected passer one could argue that
the king is now safe it is
but it's not like
white's only area of attack is the
king's side you can you can also play on
the king side in the center you could
prepare for white is pretty much
dominating here
and very importantly if you place queen
takes h4 check i had to calculate this
we dropped the bishop back to f2 and now
both of his pieces are hanging
so
um
so so that had to be factored in
and that's why i think he should have
taken on g5
oh yeah bishop takes h3 who can tell me
why this move is bad
who can tell me why this move is bad
yeah g takes f6 with tempo you attack
both bishops at the same time rook takes
h3 you're up a piece
and this only helps us open the h file
the king can just evacuate to c2
well it does a lot of things it takes
the knight the knight's a good attacker
but it loses a piece and after hg knight
g5 i would have castled the game goes on
he can go knight h5 anyway black is okay
here um i would take white for sure but
i think black is fine uh it's hard to
continue the attack
so that should have been his appropriate
reaction but opening up the h file like
this voluntarily is very difficult
and ig8 is kind of tempting to curl up
into a little ball it just doesn't help
him so h5
bishop h3 rook h3 gh5 and as i explained
in the game we do not need to rush with
recapturing this pawn
and oh yeah tommy was asking about g
takes h6 here
because this kind of threatens checkmate
the problem is knight takes h6
and now if we give this check we get a
similar position to that other line you
could play like this
but in in the context of this move being
available i just think this is a much
more powerful attacking option
um
so takes takes takes castles king g6 is
you know adds insult to injury i don't
know what he could have done here i mean
look at how his knight is totally
constrained by the pawn on g5 and taking
that pawn helps us open file so we play
rook h5
uh and then bishop g5 and this is
totally crushing
so king g6 is understandable
and the hilarious thing is that
if you if you're intimately acquainted
with the greatest defensive efforts of
tigran petrossian you might laugh
at the con at the concept of moving the
king to the center but i had an entire
lecture when i when i was teaching uh
the charlotte online camp last summer uh
to sort of very high rated kids 23 2400
this year the camp will be in person so
i might teach the same lesson
uh
i talked about a really interesting
defensive approach where
when you think of defending against an
attack on your king
the human instinct is to go into the
corner
you're tempted to go into the corner
because it feels safest
and sometimes it is but other times the
corner is the most confined place on the
board so it's much easier to check me at
the king of the corner you don't need a
lot of pieces right
smothered mate you can checkmate with a
single knight because the king is
literally
constrained by the sides of the board
and so a lecture was on certain
positions where the best way to defend
against a monster attack against your
thing is to move the king into the eye
of the storm to literally go into the
center
uh to either the center of the board or
into the eye of the attack because the
king has more escape scores it can be
easier to use other pieces to protect
the king
uh this is all very concrete stuff and
one of the games that i showed um
in that lecture is a very memorable game
from because spyro petrossian
the sparrow and petrossian played a
bunch of times and petrossian won the
first two games against him
both from losing positions
so you can see kasparov petrossian 1981
kasparov was already 26 30.
the trojan was in the final years of his
life but still incredibly strong
thanks again vp that's incredibly
generous
homeboy from sf
um
sorry
yeah so
look at
uh look at this position and look at the
attack against black's king
look at the attack against black's king
guys guys guys
before asking if this was the same tea
ground as the as was accused of cheating
look at the year that this game was
played
1981 that's 40 years ago
does tigran the trojan who was accused
by of cheating strike you as being 70
years old or 65 years old and do you
think he played kasparov and hillberg in
1981
nah
um yes you're like yep he's basically a
time traveler
see grand patron is not alive he died in
1985 i believe of cancer unfortunately
in his 50s a very premature death
sag
so
basically
in this position he's under
monster attack
absolute monster attack
so let's look at the attack the rooks
on perfect files the queen aiming at the
king every
single one of white's pieces is in the
attack every single one one two three
four five six this is a six piece attack
you don't see this every day
black has nothing going for him no
activity the only thing that black even
has is an extra pawn one extra pawn to
compensate for the most monstrous attack
of all time
so kasparov is winning here obviously
white is pretty much completely winning
but petrossian turns this around in the
span of two moves
span of two moves
now the first thing petrosian does is he
plays the move rook to a8 he tries to
hold together the a6 pawn
um sort of out of desperation he tries
to make sure that there's no sacrifice
on a6 because that was being threatened
and gary in time pressure plays a very
tempting move gary plays the move queen
to b1 this turns out to be a very big
mistake
um and this mistake believe it or not
relinquishes the advantage
now the purpose behind queen b1
is quite straightforward gary wants to
sacrifice on b5
and deliver
wait
yeah and but and deliver uh checkmate
okay so basically
why is this made because after knight b6
um i don't have the analysis on hand
so maybe this is premature for white
knight a5 rook 85
yeah i guess this is okay for white
um it's all good yeah we gotta we had a
small spoiler but i was gonna show it
anyway in a second so don't worry about
it
um
so i guess kasparov was sort of
preparing a potential sacrifice maybe he
was trying to sacrifice on a6 here
anyways the attack is horrendous
and uh
i think the human instinct would be to
sort of tuck your king away in the
corner
but you'll quickly realize that none of
this would work rook takes b5 this is
crushing
and uh as you guys probably know by now
kasparov or petrossian played king c6
uh absolutely insane move king let me
just control z a bunch of times so i can
see the game score king c6
the king goes right into the eye of the
storm except it doesn't because the
rooks
are on a and b are an a2 and b3 now they
look stupid there's nothing on the c
file so the king is relatively safest on
c6
according to kasparov he was he almost
fell out of his chair when he
saw this move played but it makes sense
and the king itself actively
participates in the defense by attacking
this bishop this bishop was one of the
big issues in black's position and
petrossian literally threatens to take
on d6
and kasparov immediately collapses he
blunders a piece kasparov goes rook b to
a3
and one of the things kasparov forgot
about is that kc6 not only attacks the
bishop that's what kasparov was trying
to defend against bishop d6 there's rook
a6 check and we have a skewer
but kasparov forgot that the knight can
now be captured by the pawn the king has
unpinned itself from the queen
and after rook a6 or k6 or k6 this isn't
checkmate you just go bishop b6 the king
is safe and black is a piece up the game
is over
um the game is over and petrosian easily
defended queen to d8
take twice on c5 the king now on c5 and
kasparov after playing rookie for
resigned without awaiting petrossian's
response because now he has virtually no
compensation the attack has fizzled out
petrossian has a million ways to win
um
and uh and this was the stunner you know
king b5 even i would say
uh probably wins the game
so
why not bishop takes c7 followed by
knight d6
yeah so why did i assume you mean here
well bishop c7 there would be king c7 um
bishop c7 king c7 that was one of the
ideas of rook a8 because now the a6 pawn
is defended by the rook
so
yeah exactly kasparov would have just
quit chess immediately and then he would
have never become world champion
so the bottom line is that king g6 these
kinds of moves can be good
except in this case the king walks into
an open file rook g1 but that's the only
reason that uh that in this case this
move was batty to his credit he walked
back to g7 rook h597 here i think i
probably should have just taken on h6
but after bishop f6 i couldn't quite
find
uh the decisive move that again it's the
umbrella method the king using the pawn
is an umbrella thank you for the five
hey it's captain ishmeister i can't keep
up with the subs today hey it's cap with
the five subs
damn girl is right
wow okay lots of support today
bishop g5 i'll take it
queen takes g5 i'll go knight g6 and
i'll shut down the g file so and now the
knight can go to f4 later so you got to
be careful man with six
stop him and you did not have to do that
you are always a welcome presence in the
chat please don't worry about that but
thank you for the six subs
min is
literally
i feel this is
i'm getting mega spoiled right now
i see what you're trying to set up too
five six
um
i don't suppose we have a um
you are never i don't want to see that
freya said we do dr lord mayonnaise of
the seven
see i pressured him into that
we got a seven dr lord mayonnaise thank
you
um oh my gosh this is getting crazy
uh i like how we just uh spontaneously
uh we're able to manufacture this
so um thank you dr lord manes thank you
min thank you hey it's cap much
appreciated
so back to the game
before i was really interrupted
basically uh oh i know they ate oh my
gosh
this is crazy
oh my god i'm
i'm in disbelief right now
yeah bang i need a gavel i need i need
to bang something
so um
back to the game and i can't i can't
seem to analyze a single move
so the reason we played f4 is to open up
more files and diagonals for our pieces
after e takes
f4 um
came the moment at which we violated all
of the rules of the position in order to
involve our queen in the attack bishop
takes c5
he has to react to that he has to take
the piece back and we play queen takes
um somebody's going to somebody's going
to give in
somebody's going to give in
oh god i see i see i see
and then and the the queen is of course
now involved in the attack
uh so in this position i i realized that
um my opponent could have gone
no i think black has just lost but maybe
he could go rook of fate somehow rook of
fate uh holds things together gh oh no
it doesn't gh bishop h8
and now it seems like maybe the king is
hiding under the pawn but
how should white uh finish the attack
here this is a very classic combination
very classic idea
um uh oh we got nine beats on pro
oh my gosh
this is crazy
yeah rook g7 is correct rook g7hg7
queen h6 queen h8
um
i am in disbelief
we got a three dollar dono from nj drist
yeah well we can't go we can't come this
far yeah exactly
thank you guys i really appreciate it so
this was winning queen have four knight
knight six queen f7 under page six is
mate this was a nice attack i mean i
think there was nothing extraordinary
here
um
we also could have even done queen takes
g6 check which is kind of funny
king g6 gh check
and this is winning king f6 rook f5 or
king f7 rook g7 but that was completely
unnecessary favorite h6 is me oh we got
ten hey it's cap
with the ten
oh my god that is just ridiculous
this is a serious sequence here six
seven eight nine ten are you no five six
seven eight nine ten are you kidding me
uh wabika was there any light squared
bishop action yeah you could have tried
e5 here and open up this diagonal
something like this but
i already saw
the possibility of involving the queen
so this just seems like a better more
straightforward option
uh if that makes sense
and if necessary we can play e5 bishop
d3 here so any questions about the game
i know there's a lot of excitement here
but i got to do my job
i really appreciate it
anybody have any questions about this
game um anywhere along
what about queen f8 here well still g
takes h6 i think
um
and after bishop e5 i mean i think we
can find a mate it takes and
this is all crushing
uh maybe we'd have to be a little bit
more careful here
well it's not my birthday but we can
pretend it is
how can black compensate the lack of
development on the quail he could that's
that's why you should have played knight
c5
um
this is all on youtube yes why not play
bishop d4 to trade the bishop instead of
taking the knight
because we took the knight in order to
involve the queen bishop d4 i considered
i considered bishop d4 i think with 100
bits but i figured that involving the
queen would be more efficient naichi six
year maybe he can play
and if you're not careful in such
situations the attack can fizzle out
quickly that's one of the problems with
attacking against good defenders is that
good defenders are not going to give you
infinite chances you have to be precise
you have to be precise
okay looks like we're all clear would
letting him take the bishop on g5 to
open the h file immediately
um i don't know i don't know when you
mean
i mean here yeah uh
no premature premature you mean just
like going something random to open the
hell premature because uh
we're not gonna be able to get a queen
here or a queen here fast enough
and sacrificing a piece is just a little
bit of a too high of a price to pay but
that's a good i mean you always have to
consider those
[Music]